madame la Présidente me rappelle au
règlement se font sur l'organisation de
nos travaux mais aussi sur les articles
44-3 et 49-3 de la Constitution quelle
violence quelle violence est faite au
Parlement après avoir bloqué avec la
complicité de la droite le vote au Sénat
pour accélérer le débat le gouvernement
sur l'ordre d'Emmanuel Macron bien
engager l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour éviter la sanction de
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'apprêtait à
rejeter le projet de réforme des
retraites ainsi le gouvernement est seul
les salariés rejettent massivement son
texte l'opinion publique est vend debout
l'unité inter syndicale est totalement
contre lui et maintenant l'Assemblée
nationale refuse de s'engager à ses
côtés malgré des tentatives honteuses de
débauchage de certains députés dans sa
solitude le gouvernement choisi de
renforcer encore son autoritarisme il a
commencé encore ce temps les débats avec
l'article 47 ans il finit en interdisant
le débat et le vote à l'Assemblée
nationale l'insalcérité l'illégitimité
du débat sont totales Emmanuel Macron le
gouvernement devrait répondre devant le
peuple d'un tel coup de force
démocratique ce gouvernement ne peut
plus rester aux affaires du pays il sème
le chaos la voie de la raison la voix de
la sagesse
UTT le retrait de ce texte les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe CRCE
vont renforcer encore leur soutien à
toutes et tous ceux qui vont redoubler
d'efforts dans le pays pour obtenir le
retrait de ce projet injuste ce projet
décidait par les marchés financiers